[Music]
says
thank y'all so much
[Music]
is
where is it
where is
daniels
this is
we are here to see this video for the
family
to see this video i spoke with the
county attorney mike cox
on the 24th and the only issue we had
who was going to see the video
we cleared that up khalil is here
to see this video what happened to his
father
and they still keeping this video from
us they say they want to make redactions
to it
redax should not be made to show it to
the son
of mr brown open the door it is time
for transparency and accountability to
take place
today today it is time
brothers and sisters
okay i'm attorney ben crump
and along with attorney harry daniels
and attorney bakari sellers we have the
honor
of representing the family
of andrew brown
it's so important y'all that we not let
them
sweep this under the rug because
apparently
before you all showed up they just
wanted to sweep it under the rug
as they have done other brothers and
sisters who have been unjustifiably
killed
by the people supposed to protect and
serve us
it's so very important that we have
transparency
because if we don't have transparency
we can never get to accountability and
if we never get to accountability
we can never get to healing and trust
and so if we want to heal this community
if we want to heal this family then
sheriff wooten
then you need to be transparent what is
it
on this video that is so damning
that you will risk your career
and risk losing your job so the people
can't see the video
what is it that's the question we have
to ask ourselves and when we think about
what we just saw happen in minneapolis
with derek shelby being held
criminally liable guilty guilty
guilty for killing george floyd
is that the reason they are trying to
hide the video
because they don't want accountability
and it's still shocking to
attorney sellers and attorney daniels
and i
and i'm sure y'all while they keep
killing so many unarmed black people
who are running away from them not
posing a threat
not posing any violence don't we have a
right to due process
why do the police get to be the judge
the jury
and the executioner so what we're here
for in elizabeth city north carolina
where all americans watching today
and all the world will be watching
tomorrow
is to say sheriff wooten you don't need
to say
no mo come on just show the video
[Music]
attorney because
hey how you doing
i uh i wish we were somewhere else
i wish ben crump wasn't so famous
i wish we had a week where
black folk weren't just dying in the
hands of law enforcement
amen you know i say often that only in
this country can you have
the trial of derrick chauvin
be interrupted by the death
of dante wright being erupted
by the death of adam toledo
be interrupted by the death of micaiah
bryant
and now we find ourselves here
in elizabeth city and so i'm tired
but not very often in my legal career do
i get the eyes of
all of you all you know what else i'm
tired of doing i'm tired of
grieving and crying i'm tired of seeing
the videos
then we protest then we have a funeral
then we have another shooting we grieve
we cry we protest and so what i want you
all to do today is a little bit
different
i want us to destroy the system that
keeps putting us in situations like this
that means i want us to make sure that
in the state of north carolina they can
no longer hide videos
from individuals who need to see it that
means i want each and every one of you
all to take out your phones right now
and i want you to
google the number of kirsten cinema and
joe manchin
i want you to call them and ask them why
they not signed on to the george floyd
justice and policing act
amen i want you to make sure that every
united states senator democrat and
republican
passes legislation so we don't have to
be in positions like this
you know it's good to protest but i'm
tired of that
i'm tired of it being cyclical because i
stand next to a young man who joins
another club of black people who will
not be able to grow up with their father
and so i'm asking you to do something a
little bit different today
they want us to go out in the streets
and they want us to get mad and they
want us to chant and march because they
know
in 7-10 days we got to go back home
and it's gonna happen all over again it
does not make sense
that the north carolina state
legislature can hide videos
like this when all we know is that
sunshine is the best disinfectant
and so i just want to see the video this
morning y'all got me off my schedule
the share told me at 11 30 i could see
the video and it's past that and i like
to stay on a regiment
so i ask you all to just be patient a
little bit more because the truth is
going to come forth
but while we are out here i need you to
get on the phones
and i want you to go ahead and call joe
and kirsten i want you to call every
republican senator a democratic senator
and make sure that they're passing
policy so that these families don't have
to be here like this
i'm standing with gwen carr behind me i
never thought i'd be doing that
the mother of eric garner is here only
in black communities
do we have mothers of people who lost
their children due to gun violence
no other community has a club like that
but we do
and so today i ask you all to think a
little bit differently about how we
gonna break this cycle
we're gonna destroy this system and
we're gonna reimagine what it should be
so we don't have no more deaths like
this
and the first step mr sheriff is simply
do one thing
show us the video
and we won't have the family address you
all until after
they see the video and it is troubling
it's very troubling that we have to go
through this
just to achieve simple justice i can't
imagine how many of these roland martin
and us have been
through the fact that
the taxpayers have paid all this money
for the police to be retrofitted
with body camera video and then the time
when it's most critically needed
they won't show it to the public why did
the taxpayers play the money
and so vicari is saying federally
we also should be acting here in north
carolina to say
it shouldn't be a judge that has decided
for us to see a video
that we've already paid our tax dollars
to see the video
that's asinine so what we have to do
is continue to be strategic
we have to literally vote the people in
office who are going to say
we want our children to be able to
live out the fulfillment of their
destiny that god
has for them and not to be shot in the
back
i mean the most cowardly thing in the
world you can do is shoot somebody in
the back
they don't shoot white men in the back
but it's almost like a cliche
where people in the black community
whether jacob blake and kenosha
where there's a laquan mcdonald in
chicago whether it's walter scott or
south carolina
whether it's terrence crutcher in
oklahoma i mean
they shoot us in the back as if the most
dangerous
thing in the world to a police officer
is a black man running away they don't
shoot these mass
murderers these young white men who are
confirmed mass
murderers i mean when you think about
the parkland school
shooting i mean they took him alive
after he shot up the whole school
you think about the young man who
went and shot up the people in the asian
spa in atlanta
they took him alive arthur and then my
lord not too far from here in bakari's
home state you know
this young white boy named dylan roof
went and shot up
uh the whole church and literally
they chased him across state lines into
north carolina and they not only took
him alive
but they took him to burger king to get
a burger fry
but andrew brown they shoot him in the
back
and we gonna see the video to know what
they
trying to hide from all of y'all because
the truth
can't hide forever and a lie cannot live
forever
i gave you all an assignment so i wanted
to follow through i need everybody to
take their phones out i know y'all feel
me but take it out we're gonna do
something good i
i got joe manchin's number right here
it's 202-224-3954
202 224 3954 call his office and tell
him we tired of black folk dying
and then kirsten cinemas numbers 202.
say the number one more time for joe
manchin 202
224 3954
and kirsten cinema is 202-224-4521
and just call our office and tell them
how you feel
let me turn it over to harry harry has
an update for you
all right so let me be clear uh
we had this thing set up uh when i say
we the family attorneys
with the county attorney mike cox
11 30 was the time it was on the 24th
the only issue we had like i said before
who was going to see
the video we cleared that issue cleared
it heard the statue we cleared it
10 29 this morning an hour before
the viewing i get an email harry
i'm getting ready to do a press release
you all seen the pledge have y'all seen
a press release from me
harry ready to do a press release that
the video is having some redactions
performed
it will not be ready at 11 30. we are
working on as hard as we can
but it takes time this intent to have it
done by the day
they had 24 hours
24 48 hours and it still ain't done they
didn't see this video
since wednesday april the 21st
to make that decision and do the
redactions show us to take the family
sheets
bro i was told by the district attorney
i was told by the district attorney that
the family
would get to see the raw footage not the
redacted version
these candidate administrators are
walking back the promises they have made
show the tape if you ain't got nothing
to hide show the tape
you all know that's very profound
i bet you if that video showed andrew
doing something wrong they would have no
problem
showing that video facebook twitter
instagram
but it only seems to be when the video
has the police doing something wrong
then they got to redact it
then they don't want to show it we we
have to
always when we get a chance to speak
truth to power so we can't do it alone
we need all of y'all speaking truth to
power
for our children because the other thing
that is profound this is khalil
khalil is the son of andrew brown julian
now you all may have noticed that they
released uh a warrant
saying all kinds of things about andrew
brown
but they want to redact the face of the
police officers
that killed andrew brown now andrew
brown didn't kill nobody
the police killed andrew brown but we're
going to protect
them and not show their face and not
say their names so we can see what their
rap [ __ ]
is because all they want to do is
assassinate
the character of his stuff
and we want to say no no we want to know
what was the character of the killers
say his name andrew brown says his name
andrew brown
[Music]
video
greetings i am keith rivers president of
the paschal tank county
branch of the national association for
the advancement of colored people
as well as the third vice president of
the north carolina state conference of
the naacp
and we will continue to demand
justice we will continue to march
we will continue to have peaceful
protests
we will continue to stand for the brown
family
and this community it is it is almost
disgraceful that he has taken the
media to to get a a notice
from the sheriff's department to release
the video
and now we're understanding that you
don't want to release the video
in its entirety you don't want to be
transparent
but you want to say that to ask the
community to trust you
well we can't trust you if you're not
transparent
we have to heal we have to grow sheriff
wooten
do the right thing the d.a
do the right thing we will continue and
let it be known
that this community has now the city has
declared
a state of emergency and it has been
through peaceful
protest peaceful protest that
is a reflection of this community
the people that are elected to office we
elected the sheriff we elected the
district attorney
we elected you do not fail
this community do not fail this
community
to all of the protesters to all of the
community out here
let the entire united states of america
hear you
what do we want what do we want
when do we want it who do we want it for
who do we want it for andrew
thank you mr president uh
we have the daughter one of the children
of andrew brown here and
if you ever want to remember what we're
fighting for
you just look at that little angel
um right now we're going to have
somebody address you
who is part of that fraternity that
nobody wants to be part of as
bakari and harry talked about she was
with
the family of george floyd
she was with the family of michael brown
she was with the family of brianna
taylor
she has been a shoulder
for them to lean on she has been
a common force for them
and for all of us she's one of the
original mothers of the movement
and she did not think it robbery
elizabeth city
to come down and be with the family of
andrew brown
she is the mother of eric garner
the first i can't breathe case
in staten island new york before george
floyd
said i can't breathe y'all let's welcome
the mother of the movement the mother of
eric
garner miss gwen carr
thank you all i just want to give honor
to god
who is first in my life and i thank you
all for standing up for justice this is
what we must do
everybody has to stand for justice we
have to gather like this i'm tired
i'm tired of coming to these
commemorations
for black men being shot
that's wavy gym
but again i come to stand in solidarity
with this family
but too much is too much
we can't even get over the trial of
george floyd
before there were several other murders
and then we come down here to elizabeth
city where they shoot a man
in the back they won't show the video
what are they trying to hide
if he had shot one of those police
officers or if he hadn't even had a
fight with those police officers
the video would be all over the nation
right now
yeah but now they're trying to hide the
police space why
they are the criminals they say that we
are armed and dangerous no
they are the ones who are armed and
dangerous who are taking our lives
they're coming to our communities
abusing and brutalizing our children
and then they tried to sweep it up under
the rug we must say no more sweeping it
under the rug
no more we want justice we want
accountability
we can't have this keep on happening and
we can't
treat it like it's the norm because
there's nothing normal
about this our children are dying
and we have the media it's another news
story
to the media but this is our lives we
have to live this
each and every day
as they say all police officers isn't
bad
or black and browns isn't
[Applause]
to treat criminals situation as it is
and i am so so i give my family this my
sympathy my love
and i stand with you as all of you do
and we have to keep on standing together
we can't go home and just sit on our
couch we have to stay woke people
thank you so much thank you
you know y'all
doing george floyd people
wrote and called us from all over the
world
saying until we get justice for george
floyd
none of us can breathe i think while we
got ms carr here
we should remind the
powers that be that we can't breathe
until we get transparency we can't
breathe
we can't breathe we can't breathe
we can't breathe we can't breathe
we can't breathe we can't breathe
we can't breathe we can't breathe
we can't breathe we can't breathe
we can't breathe thank y'all we want
miss gwen carter know
that we still remember her son eric
garner
never got his day in court and we're
still fighting for justice
for eric gardner as well thank you thank
you
all right we got a uh another update
from the county
they said they're getting real close
y'all keep the pressure on
keep the pressure on keep the pressure
stand up what do you do
what do you do
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna go take the
family gonna take the family we will be
back we get real close
and we'll reconvene after we see this
video say his name
[Music]
[Music]
says
so
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
last night
cheers
oh
i've had conversations